with the holidays fast approaching you
might want to know what to get the
descendants to fan in your life we'll
worry no longer because we're going to
give you a range of festive gift ideas
linked to one of our favorite films be
sure to stay to the end and we'll show
you a doll of one of a character we
think we all love if this is the first
time you visited the things then do us a
favor give us a thumbs up and hit the
subscribe button today we are going to
show you ten Disney descendants two
dolls and toys every fan needs evil
bowling handbag with the holidays coming
up there's a whole load of somewhat
unusual pieces of descendants and
descendants to merchandise available one
of our favorite ones is coming right up
can you believe that it's a bowling ball
bag with Evie and Mao on it we love it
because we enjoy bowling but sometimes
our balls can get rather heavy so having
something with two of our favorite
characters on it is going to help us you
can imagine being the envy of everyone
at the bowling alley as you saunter out
of carrying your equipment in this it's
the sort of thing that's a bit different
and that's why we like it so much
Oh Michelle necklace in descendants two
we got to meet a whole load of cool new
characters who we didn't see in the
first movie one of our favorites was the
film's main baddie
uma she's the daughter of Ursula from
The Little Mermaid and she absolutely
delights in leading her motley crew of
pirates against the film's heroes now in
a movie which we learn about what it
means to be the baddies so if you want
to get yourself a bit of umas style
that's cool and you can with this
necklace it's got a show and it has a
pretty cool starfish and a spooky skull
hanging off the pendant chain so you can
see why we like it
stickers something that never gets dull
is descendants - have we mentioned that
it's one of our favorite movies anyway
something else that doesn't get boring
ever is stickers they can brighten up so
many things whether it's a letter or a
notebook or even an item of furniture a
sticker can make things bright fun
colorful and exciting so it kind of goes
without saying that we absolutely adore
this massive bumper pack of descendants
- stickers they have pretty much every
character logo and design from the
gloriously classic Disney film on there
and they are going to break the bank
either
so for these holidays we would be very
happy to get these as a present then I
love the lost doll one of our favorite
parts of descendants
was when Ben had to get into the Isle of
the lost in order to find Mao who had
returned there after accidentally
falling out with him what we liked was
that Ben who so far had been clean-cut
and smartly dressed how to get a new
scuzzy or look in order to fit in with
everyone there it also inspired one of
the best songs in the movie chillin like
a villain so what is cool is that the
dolphin in your life can get their own
awesome doll of Ben on the Isle it's got
the Kings undercover threads and it's
something we like mal costume for kids
when we were kids one thing we
absolutely love to do was play dress-up
you can explore whole new worlds dressed
as one of your favorite characters and
if you've got a child who has a big fan
of mal and the chances are you do then
you can get them mixed it's an awesome
official Disney made outfit that's just
like the one malware's in descendants -
that's right it's purple and it's got
the cool studs that Maleficent's
daughter wears that make her stand out
too much we like it but we have to admit
we're a little bit jealous unfortunately
there isn't one for adults yet reusable
shopping bag what's the thing that you
do if not every day then at least once a
week well one of those regular tasks is
going shopping now in some places you
have to pay a small fee if you want a
boring disposable plastic bag so it
makes sense to get yourself a proper
shopping bag but even if that's not the
case where you live you will want to get
yourself this next item that's right
it's a descendants - shopping bag it's
got one side with Carlos Ben Evie and
mal and on the other side there's Emma
and you'll be helping the environment
twice with this because it's made from
recycled material microphone one of the
things that we like the most about
descendants - is the number of excellent
songs there whether it's ways to be
wicked chilling like a villain what's my
name or it's going down the tunes in
this movie are as good as any that have
appeared in Disney's vast pantheon of
films and we will admit it we just love
to sing along with them that's why this
next toy is so good can you see it it's
a microphone
but not just any microphone it's pink
and it's got a picture of mal along with
a long live evil motto best of all it
amplifies itself you can hear yourself
when you sing along style switch mal
doll when we first came across mal in
descendants - it's a bit of a shock if
you've seen the first film that's
because she's now King Ben's girlfriend
and she needs to behave like a princess
but it's not just that she has to look
like one she doesn't have purple hair
anymore she's dyed it blonde because
princesses aren't really
meant to have purple hair well if you
liked mail being like that then we think
that you will like this doll it's now
after she's had her style switch of
course if you've seen the movie then
you'll know that it doesn't quite go
smoothly with her new look but if it had
we wouldn't have had this movie uma
costume for kids Disney is a studio that
we absolutely love and one of the
reasons why we love it so much is
because it has given us some amazing
characters over the years but not only
that it has given us some amazing
memorable villains and when we saw
descendants too we realized pretty early
on that uma is a more than worthy
addition to the pantheon of Disney
baddies she's got a memorable look -
speaking of which if you know a child
who's a fan of Ursula's daughter then
you should get them this absolutely
awesome outfit it's a distinctive shade
of green and best of all it comes with
uma cell and gloves Eevee is wicked
fashions doll with so many great and
memorable characters it can be hard to
work out who our favorite one and
descendants two is but what we do know
for certain is that Eevee has got to be
up there she's the daughter of the Evil
Queen from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs and she's a loyal friend so
that's why we love this doll of Eevee
but it's not just Eevee it's pretty much
any kind of Eva you want because she
comes with a variety of different
outfits but that gun is thinking who is
your favorite character in descendants -
don't be shy let us know in the comments
and that's all for our 10 Disney
descendants 2 dolls and toys every fan
needs if you like to check out 10
mistakes in descendants - you might have
missed thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe